MALE SPEAKER: OK,
so welcome everybody
here in Mountain View.
And to our Googlers tuning
in around the world, good day
to you as well.
I have the privilege today of
introducing Anil Ananthaswamy.
He's a consultant for "New
Scientist Magazine," where
he has also worked as a staff
writer and deputy news editor.
His writing has also appeared
in "National Geographic News,"
"Discover Magazine,"
"The Independent,"
and the "Times
Online" in the UK.
Anil was a guest
columnist for PBS's "Nova"
on their "The Nature
of Reality" blog.
He has a master of science from
the University of Washington
at Seattle, a bachelor's
from the Indian Institute
of Technology in Madras.
And he worked as a software
engineer in Silicon Valley
before training as a
journalist at UC Santa Cruz.
He's in good company today.
Anil win the UK
Institute of Physics,
Physics Journalism Award,
and the British Association
of Science Writers Award for
Best Investigative Journalism.
His first book titled,
"The Edge of Physics:
A Journey to Earth's
Extremes to Unlock
the Secrets of
the Universe," was
voted Book of the Year in
2010 by "Physics World."
And he also delivered a
popular TED talk in 2010
titled "What it Takes to
do Extreme Astrophysics."
Today, he's here to talk about
his latest book, "The Man Who
Wasn't There: Investigations
Into the Strange New Science
of the Self."
Please join me in welcoming
Anil to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Sajit,
and thank you, everyone.
This is indeed a great
pleasure to be here.
As Sajit said, I used to
be a software engineer.
So it's particularly nice
to come and speak at Google.
I initially was wondering
whether I should give
a presentation or do a reading.
And then after
talking with Sajit,
we figured that
what I'll do is just
talk about the book in
conceptual terms for about
25 minutes.
And then we can discuss.
Sajit has some
back up questions.
But if you have
questions, then we
can dive into the
various issues.
And I'm sure the topic is such
that each one of us, because
for each one of us is a
self, we will have questions
about what that means.
So the book is called
"The Man Who Wasn't There:
Investigations Into the Strange
New science of the Self."
And basically, what I'm trying
to do in this book is really
take a look at
what neuroscience,
neuropsychology, psychiatry--
all these disciplines
are telling us about
the nature of the self.
So if you have read books
on the self-- the philosophy
of the self over the
last few decades--
you would most likely have
come across this quote
by David Hume.
He was an 18th century
Scottish philosopher.
And he was writing about
his notion of the self.
And he writes, "When I enter
most intimately into what
I call myself, I always stumble
on some particular perception
or other of heat, or cold,
light, or shade, love
or hatred, pain or pleasure.
I never can catch myself at
any time without a perception
and never can observe
anything but the perception."
And Hume traditionally
falls into what philosophers
would call the no-self camp.
He's basically saying that if
I try to examine within myself,
the thing that is doing
the perceiving-- the thing
that is experiencing
the perceptions-- he
says he's unable to find
anything but the perceptions.
So he in some sense he is saying
that the sense we all have off
being an eye that is
experiencing-- the eye that
is the subject of
experiences for him
is something that comes out of
just the bundle of perceptions
that we are.
So he falls into--
for most philosophers
today when they look
at what he said,
they would categorize
him as someone
who says there is no self.
This whole search for
the nature of the self
goes back a long way.
It's not just a
modern obsession.
It's been something
that people have been
wondering about for millennia.
And this is another example.
This comes from the
philosophical traditions
of India, which as a
country has been maybe
sometimes unreasonably obsessed
with the nature of the self.
But it has been.
And there is from-- this is
a poem from eighth century.
It's a poem of six stanzas.
And it's called the
song of liberation.
And, basically, the approach
that this particular tradition
within India takes to
try to answer who am I
is by looking at
things that you're not.
So it's basically
saying, I'm not this.
I'm not this.
So maybe what's left
over will be what I am.
So in the way each stanza
progresses, it basically
identifies the things
that one is not.
So the poem is saying I'm not
the mind, nor the intellect,
nor any entity that identifies
self with ears, tongue, nose,
or the eyes-- not even proceeded
by space, light, or the wind--
I am.
So in this particular poem,
the last line of each stanza
is an answer to what I am.
But it is an answer
particular to that tradition
within Indian philosophy.
And even within
India, for instance,
there are numerous
traditions that
have examined this question.
And each one has
their own answer.
So the point is not
to focus on the answer
given by this
particular tradition
because they have
their own take on it.
And it's an article of
faith after a point.
But I'm just pointing
out that this
is a question that has
obsessed all of humanity
for millennia, literally.
And in some sense,
it is the question
that I'm asking in
the book-- who am I?
And looking specifically
at what neuroscience
is telling us about.
But before we get into
talking about some
of the neuropsychological,
psychiatric conditions
that help us
understand a little bit
about the nature
of the self, what
is it that we're talking about
when we talk of the self.
And here's something
that philosophers
like to talk about.
So I'll set that
up a little bit.
And then we'll come
to what lay people
like us might appreciate more.
So for philosophers,
there's something
called synchronic unity.
So if you think of
what we are right
now-- you are seeing something.
You're hearing something.
You're probably feeling
the touch of your clothes
on your skin.
So they are tactile sensations.
And what's not trivial
and quite amazing
is the fact that the
person seeing something
is the same as a person
hearing something.
And it's the same
person feeling the touch
on the skin-- feeling
the temperature
of the air on your skin.
So there is a certain
unity to your experiences.
It's not like someone is hearing
and you don't have a sensation
that, oh, someone else
is hearing the sounds
and someone else is feeling
some other sensation.
All the sensations that
your body is receiving
is being experienced
by the same entity.
This might seem
very trivial to us
because that's how
we experience life.
But, actually, from a
philosophical perspective,
it's quite a big, big deal.
There is a certain unity
to that experience.
From a neurobiological
perspective,
it's also a big deal
to try and explain
how come all of these sensations
feel like they're being
experienced by the same entity.
I'm not saying
person-- same entity.
What is that thing?
So philosophers
call it synchronic
unity-- this unity at
this present moment.
All your experiences
have that unity.
There's also another
kind of unity.
And, again, if you think about
who you are in your head,
if you think back to you when
you were four years old or 10
years old and also
think into the future
and imagine your future
self, those rememberings
and imaginings are going to
bring up emotions-- bring up
perceptions in your mind.
And, again, if you
really ponder upon that,
all those perceptions--
whatever arises in your mind,
again, feel like they're
happening to the same entity.
You don't feel like
your 10-year-old self
is something or
someone different
than your present self.
And the imagined future
itself doesn't feel like it
someone different.
It is still being experienced
as things that are happening
or happened to the same entity.
So this is another
kind of unity--
a unity that spans time and
it's called synchronic unity.
And, again, philosophers
wonder and worry about this.
How come?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You said
the first thing was--
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Oh, sorry,
diacrhonic-- the second one.
Thank you.
The second one is
diachronic unity.
And, again, it's
not a trivial thing
to try and explain
neurobiologically how
does the brain achieve this?
Or if indeed it's
the brain doing it.
How does it happen?
So these are the
kind of questions
that when you talk of the
self from a philosophical
perspective, these are the
two big things that they're
trying to explain.
Is what is it behind this unity?
Why does it feel like that there
is same entity experiencing
all the things that
we're experiencing
right now and over time.
For the rest of us, if you
leave philosophers aside,
if you look at how William
James-- William James
was a great American
psychologist and physician
who wrote a lot about the self.
He kind of talked about
facets of the self.
So self-- each
one of us is never
the same thing all the time.
We have different
aspects-- different facets
that show up in
different situations.
So one of the
things James did was
to divide the self
into something
called the material me, which is
everything that is me or mine.
So anything your mind that has
a sense of mindness whether it's
your body whether it's your
relationships whether it's
things you possess-- all
of those things for him
were the material me.
He then talked of
the social self.
Every time you have a social
interaction with someone,
there is a sense you
have of what you are.
That is specific to
that interaction.
You may be talking to your boss.
He'll have a certain kind of
feeling about what you are.
You will be talking to
someone who works for you.
You'll have a different
sense for what you are.
So social self is a
very integral part
of our larger sense of self.
He then talked of something
called the spiritual self--
the sort of internal psychic
faculties we all have.
So that's one way of
thinking about yourself.
You can slice and dice
how we think of ourselves
into different facets.
The division, or the
kind of categorization
that I really like in terms
of trying to understand what
we are is this second one,
which is dividing the self
into something called
the narrative self
and the bodily self.
The narrative self
is the easiest
to understand in some
sense because if I
were to ask you who are you?
Some of you will say,
oh, I work at Google.
I was at Yahoo.
I'm planning to go to Bing--
whatever your ideas might
be about yourself.
But I don't even know
whether Bing exists.
So the point is that you
have a story in your heads
about who you are.
And it's a story
not only that you
tell others about who you are.
But it's a story that
you tell yourself.
It's not even a cognitive
telling of the story.
It's how you feel
about yourself.
There is a narrative
in your head.
And it's a cognitive narrative.
And it's also embodied-- there
are aspects of one's narrative
self that is in the body.
For instance, if you learned
how to ride a bicycle.
Now, you can tell someone-- oh,
I know how to ride a bicycle.
That's a cognitive
retelling of your story
because that is
part of who you are.
But the ability to ride a
bicycle is actually embodied.
It's not something that
you consciously recall.
It's there in your body.
And it's part of your narrative.
So there are many, many
aspects of who we are,
which is really deeply
embedded in the body.
And you can think
of all these things
as forming your narrative.
But there is another
aspect of yourself.
If your narrative were
to completely shut down--
if you forget the
fact that we have here
sitting at Google
completely let go
of all the thoughts about
the story that you are,
you still are a
body experiencing
being here and now.
There is a sense I have of being
in this volume of space which
is occupied by my body.
I have a sense of ownership.
I look at my body, and
it feels like mine.
And I have a perspective that
I'm looking out at the world
from within my head
from behind my eyes.
And I also have the sense
that what I'm perceiving
is private to me-- that
I have a first-person
perspective on the world.
And each one of you
looking this way,
you're all kind of aware
that even though you're all
looking at the same thing,
you all have a sense
that your sense of what you're
seeing is private to you.
And that's part of
what the bodily self is
that there is something--
AUDIENCE: What
your saying is it's
like what you would
perceive if you
had memories about your
past or who you were?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Yeah,
assume that for some reason
your narrative shut down,
and this is a good example
that I gave you.
You had amnesia and you
completely forgot everything
about who you were in terms
of the story that you are.
Your memories are gone.
But you would still
be a bodily self.
So this is another
way of thinking
about what the self might be.
How does the brain
and the body together,
how do they combine to create
these aspects of the self?
So basically now given
these kinds of definitions,
if you were to read about
the self and philosophies
of the self and
neuroscientists, there
are still arguments going on
about whether there is a self
or whether there is no self.
Is the self an illusion?
And if so, who's illusion is it?
So these are--
these are arguments
that continue to go on.
And one of the things
that even if you go back
maybe 30, 40 years
within neuroscience,
there was this idea that
the self is something
separate from the
brain and body.
So one of the questions
about whether there is a self
or whether there is no self
was about this question of
is the self a
fundamental constituent
of nature just as electrons
and quarks and gluons
are fundamental aspects
of the material world.
So if the body and
brain went away,
would the self still exist?
Does the self persist beyond
the depth of the brain and body?
These were questions
that we're being asked
and in some sense, what
philosophers call ontology,
the self-- what they were
asking is does the self
have its own unique
ontological status?
Can it be part of as a
fundamental aspect of nature?
And that argument
now-- pretty much
most neuroscientists and
philosophers would say no.
That's not true.
The self is really
something that
arises from the brain and body.
And it doesn't persist
after you're dead.
So there is no
ontological status
that it has that is separate
from the fundamental aspects
of the material world.
But that doesn't
mean that the debate
about whether there
is a self are no self
has gone away completely.
And in some sense, what I
tried to do in this book
is to take the leaders
along the journey
by looking at various
neuropsychological conditions
to appreciate what is the
heart of the argument.
There is still an argument.
But it's not clear
from the outset
if you just read stuff in
newspapers about the self
being an illusion, what is it
that they're arguing about?
So the whole book is an
effort to bring the reader
to the point where
you can say, ah,
that's what we're arguing about.
The argument still persists.
It's not resolved because we
don't have empirical evidence.
But it's a very, very
subtle and fine point
that they are fighting
over, the philosophers,
which is what they do.
So disturbances of the
self-- in the book I
look at these eight
different conditions.
I'll talk about a few.
I don't think we'll have time
to go through all of them.
But I'll just mention a few.
But these other ones--
Cotard's syndrome
in which people believe
and are convinced
that they don't exist.
Alzheimer's is a disease,
which unfortunately a lot of us
would be familiar
because we know someone
who is suffering from it.
Alzheimer's, as a disease,
destroys the narrative self.
Body integrity
identity disorder has
to do with notions of
ownership of body parts
and tells us something
about the bodily self.
Schizophrenia tells us
something about what's
called the sense of agency.
I'll come to this in a minute.
Depersonalization disorder
tells about the role
of emotions and the self.
Autism tells us something
about self awareness
in terms of being able
to read someone's mind
to have a sense of
oneself and also something
about the bodily self.
Autoscopic phenomena are things
like out-of-body experiences,
which we have all heard about.
And out-of-body
experiences tell us
a lot about how the
brain actually constructs
the in-body experience.
In order for us to have
an out-of-body experience,
we should first be in-body,
which we are right now,
hopefully, all of us
are in-body right now.
And by looking at
how the brain manages
to create out-of-body
experiences,
we actually learn
a lot about how
we end up being in this body.
And then there's a very
paradoxical condition
called ecstatic epilepsy
where people feel ecstatic,
joyful, blissful.
And they feel their body state
and environment very intensely.
But, paradoxically,
they also feel
like some boundary
between themselves
and the outer world
has disappeared.
And they feel one with the
larger Universe-- the other.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What
triggers [INAUDIBLE]?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
Meditation can induce
autoscopic phenomena, yes.
You can have out-of-body
experiences while meditating.
But this is purely
a neurological or
neuropsychological condition
that I'm talking about.
So let's look at a few of these.
This is one of the
most intriguing ones.
I don't know how many
of you've heard of this.
Cotard syndrome is
a condition that
was identified by a
French doctor called
Jules Cotard in the late 1800s.
And it's a constellation
of symptoms
that have to come
together for the person
to be diagnosed
as having Cotards.
But the most intriguing
symptom in that syndrome
is this feeling, or
conviction, that the person
has that they are dead--
that they don't exist.
And I'm seeing a few
puzzled faces already.
And that's exactly how it should
be because what does that mean?
So in some sense, all of us
here are probably, hopefully,
really convinced
we exist, right?
It should not be
a matter of doubt.
We do.
I mean, it is our-- it's not
even something you'll question.
Now, imagine someone
sitting right
next to you who was
equally convinced that they
don't exist.
And it happens.
So, fortunately, it's an
extremely rare condition.
Only a few hundred
cases have been
recorded in medical literature.
And it's also a state
in which the person
experiencing Cotard's
is extremely depressed.
And it's a depression
that the psychiatrist
that I've talked to say that
it is far worse than even
the depression that
we are traditionally
aware of that people who
are clinically depressed
would experience.
This is something that goes
well beyond that sometimes.
But there is some
alteration in the way
they perceive their
own body states
and their own
emotions and feelings.
It's kind of a
complete dampening
down off the vividness
off our experience
of being a body that is
causing this perception
to arise in their brain
that they don't exist.
In addition to that, they
seem to have some things that
have gone wrong
in the brain where
some rational
aspects of the brain
are also not functioning
well, which then prevents them
from rationally shooting
down this perception that
has arisen within them.
So it's kind of a
two-factor theory
to explain you know why
that might be happening.
From a perspective of
the self and philosophy,
it's a very
intriguing phenomenon
because you can still
ask, OK, so who or what is
the I that says I don't exist?
Right?
So just like all of
us will say, I exist.
They can say, I don't exist.
There is still an I that
experiences either existence
or nonexistence.
So in terms of understanding how
neurobiologically the brain is
bringing about this the sense
of being an I-- the I is still
there, even in Cotard's, even
the person who is saying I
don't exist, the I still exists.
So what is that I?
That's the question.
In some sense, that
is the question
that this pursued
throughout this book
by looking at the
various conditions
and trying to understand
what aspects of ourselves
are integral to the I
and what aspects are not.
So remember the
earlier discussion.
You can start by
saying I'm not this.
I'm not this.
So you can keep doing that.
And you can-- and these
neuropsychological conditions
allow us to kind of look
at ourselves in that way
by saying, OK, I'm not the sense
of existence or nonexistence
because that seems to
be a property that I'm
aware of that is still an I that
can experience that existence
or nonexistence.
So the question
remains what is the I?
So am I a narrative in the
sense that am I my story?
We were just talking about
sort of the larger story
in our heads about who we are.
It turns out if you--
Alzhiemer's disease,
one of the things
it does, it stops--
it basically prevents
short-term memory
from becoming long-term memory.
It's essentially you're
unable to form new memories.
Now, when you think about
your narrative self,
a key component of
that is the ability
to remember what
has happened to you.
You have to be able
to string together
episodes in your life to kind of
give it-- form that narrative.
Now, if a disease like
Alzheimer's comes along
and basically puts a halt to
the formation of new memories,
in some sense it has
stopped the narrative self
from growing any further.
So at the disease onset, it's
almost like the narrative self
stops forming.
But unfortunately, Alzehimer's
doesn't stop at that point.
The ravages of the disease are
such that it actually starts
eating away existing memories.
So in a sense, it starts
scrambling the narrative
that you already had and
eventually pretty much
completely destroying that.
So now if you talk to
caregivers and people who
take care of patients and
people with Alzheimer's, they're
going to say things
like, especially
when the person is in the
late stages of the condition,
they'll say things like,
oh, there's no one in there.
You will hear these phrases.
The self, the person
that I knew is gone.
So they have-- at
least from the outside,
we have this impression that
whoever was the person that you
knew is no more because there
is almost no interaction with
the person, you can't-- you
can't infer anything about what
might be happening within
the person suffering from
Alzheimer's.
It's very clear that the
narrative self is gone.
Now, philosophers,
there are philosophers
who argue that all that
we are is a narrative.
You take away the narrative.
And there is no I. The I comes
about because of the narrative,
whether it's
cognitive or embodied.
And Alzheimer's is forcing
us to ask that question
very seriously because
once the narrative is gone,
once the person is
unable to have a story
to relate to oneself
or to others,
does it mean that there
is no one in there?
Really?
I mean, in the sense is there
no one there feeling pain
as their own?
Is there no one in there
feeling hunger as their own.
Can they not feel their
own body as their own,
even though the story is gone?
That is an unanswered
question right now
because we can't
communicate with people
with end stage Alzheimer's and
ask these questions of them.
And it's a very
debilitating condition.
But it does throw up
a really important
philosophical and
neuro-scientific question
about what remains after
the narrative is gone.
And for that, you can
start kind of looking at
in order to understand what
might be happening there.
There are other conditions
that tell us a little bit more
about how the self
might be put together.
So body integrity
identity disorder,
this is also probably a
condition that some of you
may have heard about
it, but not others.
So I'll just read out
this quote from a book
by Oliver Sacks He had an
accident after which he
felt like this.
And he wrote about it.
"The leg suddenly assumed
an eerie character,
or more precisely,
if less evocatively,
lost all its character and
became a foreign, inconceivable
thing, which I
looked at and touched
without any sense whatever
of recognition or relation.
I gazed at it and felt, I don't
know, you're not part of me.
So he's basically saying
that his leg did not
feel like his own.
Now this was a transient
condition for him.
And it improved.
And he was OK.
But it's a condition that
actually can haunt some people
throughout their life.
And it's actually
quite debilitating
and can lead them to take some
pretty desperate measures.
So one way to understand
what body integrity identity
disorder might be is to
think about phantom limbs.
And this is something I'm sure
most of you have heard of.
If someone has had
an amputation because
of an accident or an
infection, and they
will-- some people who've
had this amputation will say,
oh, I continue to feel my limb.
So now it's very clear
that the limb is gone
because it has been amputated.
But they continue to feel
the presence of that limb.
Some will even feel pain in
the limb, in that phantom limb.
And that's called phantom pain.
Now, what that is
telling you very clearly
is that what has happened
is that the limb is gone
but a representation of the limb
in the brain still persists.
Somehow the brain's
representation of the limb
hasn't reorganized.
At least that's one
theory for what's
happening when you have
to explain the perception
of a phantom limb.
So it's basically
telling us that when
you perceive your body,
what you're perceiving
is a representation
or information
about the body in the brain,
not the actual physical limb.
And if everything
is working well,
the brain's representation
of your body and your body
should be the same.
And so everything works well.
But there are situations like in
phantom limbs where the limb is
gone because of the amputation.
But the representation
hasn't changed yet
for whatever reason.
And you continue
to feel that limb.
So what you're feeling, what
you're perceiving to be a body
is actually information
in the brain.
Now, you can imagine the
opposite scenario, which
is BIID, where the limb is
there-- functional, healthy,
everything is fine except that
the representation in the brain
is somehow not quite caught up
with the actual physical body.
But because your
reality is determined
by what is in the brain in
terms of the representation,
the information content
that the brain has,
or the model that the
brain has of the body,
your reality will be
dictated by those models.
And if the model for
some reason does not
include part of your limb
or has some mismatch,
that mismatch can be
quite debilitating.
And in this particular
case, people
will actually go to great
lengths to amputate that limb.
So this will be a
voluntary amputation.
They will actually go and
get a part of their leg
or a part of their
arm amputated.
And then, paradoxically, they
will say I feel complete now.
So until then, they felt--
they felt miserable.
And, actually, taking that limb
off, that part of the body--
it could be any part
of the body but,
usually, it seems to be
the extremities of limbs--
it's the amputation
that leads to relief
at least at this point of our
understanding of the disorder.
But what is that telling
us about the body itself?
It's very, very clear
at some very basic level
if the understanding-- the
neuroscientific understanding
of this is correct--
then what it's telling us
is that our bodily self,
the body that we perceive,
is really a model in the brain.
And that model needs
to be congruent
with the physical body.
And if everything is working
well, it will be congruent.
And so reality will match
the information content.
But sometimes
there's a mismatch.
And, unfortunately for
us, it's the information
that is sacrosanct,
not the physical body.
And so when the brain constructs
our sense of bodily self,
it's relying on those
maps in the brain.
And those maps seem to be truth.
And you can't shake
that perception.
So let me just quickly touch
on schizophrenia and then
we'll go to a Q&A. Now
schizophrenia again
is fairly common, 1%
to 2% of the population
worldwide suffer from this.
And one of the things that
happens in schizophrenia
is people hear
voices in their heads
that don't feel like theirs.
And they have thoughts
in their heads
that don't feel like theirs.
And all of this leads to an
altered sense of reality.
This is what it's
called psychosis.
And it seems like one of
the basic neurobiological
mechanisms that's
leading to all this
is something called
loss of sense of agency.
Now, if for instance, if I had
a bottle of water somewhere,
I don't.
But if-- yeah, there you go.
That's just an example.
So if I pick up this
bottle of water,
I have a very distinct
feeling that I'm doing this.
It's not a doubt in my mind.
All of us, no matter what
we do, hopefully, you
will feel that you are doing it.
It's a very implicit sense
you have of your actions.
And philosophers have long
argued that the sense of I,
the I that we are, comes from
being agents of our actions,
comes from the sense of agency.
So because we do
actions and because we
feel like we're the agents
of the actions that we do,
the sense of an I
somehow is constructed
from the sense of agency.
What happens in
schizophrenia, unfortunately,
is that they might
do the same thing.
They might pick up
the bottle of water.
And it will not feel
like they did it.
So it will actually feel
like, oh, I'm picking it up.
But I didn't will this action.
This is not me doing it.
And some neurobiologists
have looked at schizophrenia
at least in some
particular scenarios.
What they have
found is that there
is a mechanism in our
brain that kind of tags
this action as mine and
refers that action back
to the I, whatever that I is.
And in schizophrenia, it
seems like that mechanism
of tagging in action
as mine has gone wrong.
And what it's telling you is
that actually sense of agency
is not constituting
the I because here
I am lifting my bottle of water.
And I feel like I did it.
If you are suffering
from schizophrenia,
you would lift that bottle.
And you may feel, oh,
this is not me doing it.
This is not I. I'm
not doing this.
But, again, you can have the
sense of I owning that action.
Or you can have the sense
of I not owning that action.
The I still persists.
So the question-- it still
comes back to the same question.
What or who is that I
that either perceives
the sense of agency or doesn't
perceive a sense of agency?
So schizophrenia just tells
you that at least your I is not
coming from your
sense of agency,
that there is
something still basic
that needs to be explained in
order to understand the self.
And this is sort of
how the book proceeds.
I basically go through
depersonalization disorder,
autism, autoscopic phenomena,
which includes things
like autoscopic hallucinations
where you perceive
a body next to you or
doppleganger effect
where you perceive a double.
Your own body in front of you.
And you can have an
interaction with that
double where you are either
located in your physical body
or you're located in the
illusory body in front of you.
You can have
out-of-body experiences.
These are classical
out-of -body experiences
where people report just
leaving their body altogether
and observing the physical
body from, say, the ceiling.
All of these things
are telling you
something about how
the brain constructs
the bodily self, how it actually
creates an in-body experience.
Then ecstatic epilepsy,
I mentioned this earlier.
So all of these
things, if you just
look at them from the
perspective of people
who are actually suffering
from these conditions
and understand what it is
like to be experiencing
these various conditions,
then it actually
tells a lot about how the
brain might be putting together
the self in the first place.
And that's sort of what
the arc of the book is.
And in the end in the epilogue,
I come to essentially taking
all this information that
neuropsychology and psychiatry
is telling us then to ask
questions about, well,
is there a self?
Or is there no self?
And I will not answer that here
right now because it's actually
a very, very subtle point.
But it comes down
somewhere to understanding
the nature of consciousness.
There are still
people who persist
in-- I shouldn't say pursue--
there are still people who
insist that there is a self.
But it's a particular
neural process
in the brain that needs
to hold a few moments
of our experience.
We are Google and we're
all software engineers.
So we can understand
the notion of a buffer.
So you can imagine a buffer off
a few moments of experiences.
And you can have a
moment of experience
that is somehow
creating this unity
that we talked about earlier.
And you can have a few
moments of experience
prior to that and a few
moments of experience that
are predicted by the
brain to come after that.
And somehow the
brain manages to keep
a buffer of such experiences
to create a very minimal self.
And then from there, it starts
constructing the larger self
that we are, which is either the
narrative or the social in all
of those things.
The bundle theorists like
David Hume-- and there
are a lot of modern
philosophers who
will fall into that category
who basically say, look,
the sense of I that
you are is just
something that appears because
of the interaction of all
the perceptions and various
aspects of herself that
there, is if you go looking
for it, there is nothing there.
And then there
are people who say
that actually the
self fundamentally
is a property of
consciousness itself.
And there we hit a wall because
consciousness is such a problem
for neuroscience right now.
And that would be a
huge talk in itself.
But once you come down to that
level of debate about the self,
you can't escape talking
about consciousness.
And it's very integral to this
whole question of is there
a self or is there no self.
So I will stop here.
And then we can have questions.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I
guess this relates
to the schizophrenia framework
and the agents of action.
I used to think of
when I did things
as-- every time I do something,
I'm making a conscious decision
to do that.
But at some point,
I realized that it
seems that often you set part of
your body off on a subroutine.
You're out walking.
And you tell your
legs, OK, walk.
I'm going to go to
wherever I'm going.
And then while you're
walking, you're
not thinking about walking.
You're thinking about doing
whatever else you're doing.
Or, similarly, you're
carrying something,
even though your
arm is getting tired
and it wants to quit
lifting it-- lift carrying
the heavy object that you have--
it still does it until you tell
it that it's done.
So how does that relate
to this-- so yes,
how does that relate to
the agenthood of action
if you're setting your body
on subroutines like that?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Well,
the implicit assumption
in your question is that there
is a split between the mind
and body-- that
there is something
that is outside the
body, in some sense,
you telling the body
to do something.
And what neuroscience is
showing us is actually
that split is definitely not
as stark as it intuitively
feels to us.
We kind of feel that
there is that split,
and hence, centuries
of philosophy
that comes from Descartes--
I think, therefore
I am-- and all of that
fallout from that.
The whole mind-body
split was such a big deal
for such a long time.
But over the last few decades
I thik even neuroscience
has moved away from that.
So it's not quite as simple
as saying, I told my I guess,
we're in a software
company because we
were talking about subroutines.
But, basically, it probably
is not as simple as that.
The body has its
own intelligence.
And the brain and body are
very, very tightly coupled.
So what might seem like giving
instructions is probably not
as simple as that.
So the body is probably
giving ample feedback.
And you're unconsciously
probably responding
to a lot of those things.
And by the time
something filters
into conscious awareness,
a lot of processing
has happened that
we're not aware of.
So your body and brain are
already adjusting and doing
a lot of things for you before
it enters conscious awareness.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I have
a question quite related
to what you were just saying.
So if you have a very
materialistic view
of the world--
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
Sorry, say that again.
AUDIENCE: If you have a
very materialistic view
of the world, You can
come to the conclusion
that willpower is
actually an illusion.
I feel like I'm choosing
to raise my hand.
But actually the world
is one big algorithm.
And out of that,
my hand just moves.
And I think I chose to do that.
My question is that even when
no matter how hard I believe
in materialism, why is
it that I still feel like
I have willpower?
No matter how hard
I tried not to,
there is no way not to feel the
idea that we have willpower.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Yeah, I don't
get into the whole question
of whether there's a will
or not because that's
another big, big
question in itself.
But the sense of agency
that I was talking about--
actually, the neurobiological
mechanism at some level
has a very simple
model, which is
that say you decide
to move your arm,
your brain is going to send
motor commands to your arm
to move the arm.
So say I'm going to
move my arm to pick up
this bottle of water.
Then my brain is going to send
commands to the arm to do that.
At the same time, the brain
sends a copy of those commands
to other parts of the brain that
are going to predict the sensor
consequences of lifting that.
So now you have two
things happening.
One is a prediction
in the brain that, oh,
my arm is going to
move and is going
to feel the cold
temperature and also
a certain amount of weight.
It's expecting some sensory
consequence to that action.
And then the actual sensory
consequences happen.
And they are fed
back into the brain.
And the brain compares the two.
So there is a prediction
that is compared
against what actually happened.
And if the competitor
comes up again,
it's lovely being in
a software company
because all these
things make sense.
So the comparator then
basically says, ah,
my prediction
matches the outcome.
So it must be I.
If for some reason,
the competitor's output
was such that it showed a
mismatch, that implicitly gets
tagged as a non-self
or that's why
you don't have a sense of
agency if you lift it up
and for some reason,
that whole pathway that
has to compare prediction with
the actual sensory outcome.
There's a problem in
that pathway somewhere.
And you can end up
with a sensation
of not doing something
yourself, even though you
were the one we initiated.
And your brains send the
motor commands to the arm.
So it was in that context that
I mentioned sense of agency.
So it was not so
much about willpower.
There is some
argument to be made
that even the sense
of having a will
is a consequence of this
sense of agency coming about.
If the sense of
agency is disrupted,
then you-- you will
doubt your own will
because you will feel
like, oh, I didn't do that.
MALE SPEAKER: We've
got a question
from somebody watching on live
stream-- one of our Googlers.
And he's asking, "What does deep
sleep tell us about the self?
What happens to the
self during deep sleep?"
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Oh, so--
in terms of if you're dreaming
and if you're aware
of your dreams,
there is a self in
that dream-- that self.
And it's, again, the
same self in some sense.
But in your dreams, you can
do all sorts of weird things
that you can't do with
your bodies in waking life.
So, obviously, again
that kind of tells you
that it's information
processing at the heart of it.
In deep sleep, it disappears.
And it's almost like that part
of the brain is shut down.
And we don't know.
We can't query the
brain at that point.
No one can come out
of that-- and we just
don't have access to that.
So it's very unclear
in terms of the self
as to what happens
at that point.
The traditional explanation
for that in the way
one would understand
modern neuroscience
would be that whatever
brain processes work
to create our sense of self,
those processes shut down.
And you-- and it's part of
also losing consciousness
because when you're
in deep sleep,
you're not conscious either.
So they must all be
related on some level.
AUDIENCE: I listened to
your Terry Gross interview
last week.
And so when I found out
you were coming today,
I was over the moon.
I have a question about
the Cotard's syndrome.
You mentioned that there's
only a few hundred cases known.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: A few
hundred cases recorded.
AUDIENCE: Oh, recorded.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
There probably
are lots of people
experiencing it.
But in terms of medical
literature, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, that was
going to be my question.
Are there any living people
that you perhaps met with
or psychiatrists--
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
Cotard syndrome
was the only syndrome in
the book where I actually
couldn't meet a person
who was suffering from it.
It's a transient
condition, thankfully.
And it's very, very severe.
So when it's happening
it's really hard to-- you
have to be in touch
with the psychiatrists
or neuropsychologists who are
treating them at that point.
So in this one condition,
I couldn't actually
meet someone in person.
So I had to understand
what was happening
by talking to their doctors and
having them tell me what they
understood of the condition.
For all the other
conditions, I did meet people
who could narrate
and who could tell me
what it was like to be
suffering from schizophrenia
or suffering from autism.
This was the only
one where I couldn't.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
know where does ego stand
in all of this self theory?
Is it just the
materialistic self?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
I of the ego as more
of the narrative component of
ourselves-- the story that we
are.
Now, if you think about it,
the story has no boundaries.
You can make up any story
you want in your head.
It may not have a
basis in reality.
So there is a conceptual
aspect to ourselves.
We can conceive of ourselves
in many different ways.
And in some sense to me,
the ego would be that.
So the bodily self is
something very basic.
It's something
potentially animals have.
It's one of the more primitive
aspects of what we are.
And on top of that, you
have this entire cognitive
construct, which
is the narrative.
So that to me would be the ego.
And that's the thing that
could lead us into trouble
more often than not
because you can--
you can imagine conceiving
of yourself in very
grandiose terms-- like just
narcissism, for instance,
is just a narrative gone wild.
And that's a problem also.
So I think keeping our
narratives in check
is probably a very good thing.
AUDIENCE: Continuing that
question about deep sleep,
I was wondering about
deep sleep versus a coma.
Is there any
interesting difference
in terms of the
study of the self?
Is it totally out of scope?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: I could tell
you a little bit about a coma.
There is a neurologist
at the University Liege
in Belgium, Dr. Steven Laureys.
He studies a lot of patients who
are suffering from coma or are
what's called unresponsive
wakefulness, something that
used to be called
the vegetative state,
but more appropriately
now is being
called unresponsive wakefulness
or locked-in syndrome.
So these are all various
stages of being conscious.
And what he's
found is that there
are two networks
in the brain that
are correlated with
either external awareness,
awareness of sensations that
are coming from outside the body
into us or an internal
awareness network that
is responsible for our
awareness of our own body
and its internal states
and thoughts about oneself,
so self-referential thinking.
So there are these two networks.
And they seem to
be anti-correlated.
So if you are really
paying attention
to something outside of
you, then the network--
the external awareness
network is highly active.
And the internal
awareness network
is damned down and vice versa.
And it turns out that
in coma patients,
the metabolic activity in those
networks is way, way down.
So something goes wrong
where you are aware.
And there must be some
other reasons also.
There are other parts
of the brain that
are responsible for
arousal, just sort
of becoming-- as soon as
you come out from sleep,
something has to switch on.
And then all the other
activity has to kick in.
So in coma, those things
are somehow affected badly.
But then if you go to
the other conditions
like unresponsive wakefulness,
locked-in syndrome,
you'll see differing
levels of activity
in these networks
suggesting that it's
a gradation of consciousness.
MALE SPEAKER: We have
another one from a Googler
tuning in from live stream.
"What do intentionally-altered
states of conscious
tell us about our sense of self?
I.E. everything from positive
methods such as a runner's
high to the negatives
such as substance abuse,
particularly in light of new
ways to measure the effects
scientifically?"
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
I think any time
you alter your state
of consciousness,
it's a way of
examining-- essentially
what you're altering is the
contents of your consciousness.
So you are always--
hopefully always conscious.
But what's changing is the
content of that consciousness
in some sense.
And that is giving
you an idea of how
the self feels at that point.
So if, for instance, you've
taken some psychedelic which
disrupts some part of
your brain that now
can't keep a coherent narrative.
Somehow the narrative
part of you has shut down
or has fragmented.
So it's basically telling
you that these are all things
that the brain has to work
really hard moment by moment
to keep it coherent.
And you can do
things to disrupt it.
So in some sense,
they're giving you
clues about brain
mechanisms that are actually
working normally and
creating the sense of self
because it-- just
being in body right now
means that the brain
has to integrate
all the information that is
coming in from outside the body
and from within the body.
And it is, in some sense,
sampling information
and integrating all
of the information,
and creating a perception
of your body at this moment.
And it's doing so
moment by moment.
And you're perceiving
a continuous whole
because of this integration.
And you can disrupt
that integration
whether you do it because
of a runner's high.
I would imagine a
runner's high is gong
to disrupt your narrative self.
You're not thinking about
stories in your head anymore.
You become acutely aware of your
own body and your environment.
So quite similar to
probably ecstatic epilepsy.
And psychedelics
can do the same.
So they do give us clues about
how the self is constructed.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: A couple
of quick ones.
At first, it looked
like at the end,
you were trying to use
or say consciousness
might be the glue
that ties it together
and identify with self.
And yet, then I thought
a little more in saying,
no, you have the conscious
person saying that wasn't me.
So there's some tension
there I want to hear about.
And then a side question--
I've heard of these experiments
where there's timing going on
for when a decision happens.
And one of the
striking findings is
the person will say this is--
this is when I've decided it.
And yet the report
comes up that something
was happening in the
brain, I don't know, 100,
150 milliseconds earlier.
And does that speak
to any of the notion
of where the self really is.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: So let's
take the second question first.
And then we'll come
to consciousness.
So there was a very
classy experiment
that was done at UC Berkeley
by Benjamin Libet-- I think
it was in the '80s where it
was an experiment that showed
that a person's sense of when
he or she did something was
actually came after some signal
in the brain that had actually
initiated that action.
So it was almost as
if your sense of will
was being constructed
after the fact.
That experiment-- people
have tried to repeat it.
And it turns out that
maybe we didn't quite
understand exactly what
that brain signal was
that he was looking at.
So there are-- there have
been various studies that
have followed on.
It's still being debated.
It's not entirely clear.
It's possible that the
sense of having a will
is also a construction
in a sense.
But it's up for debate.
I don't think that
question has been resolved.
In terms of
consciousness, there are
philosophers and
neuroscientists who
will argue that
all the self is is
just moments of consciousness.
So consciousness-- you
can talk of consciousness
as having a property
called reflexivity
where a moment of
consciousness, regardless
of whether there's a
person-- something that
is capable of consciousness.
And if there is a
moment of consciousness,
then that moment might have
the property of reflexivity
where it's aware
of being conscious.
It doesn't mean there is a
subject or a person behind it.
It's just the nature of--
or the intrinsic property
of conscious experience.
Now, you can imagine
all that we are
is a string of conscious
experiences, each one of which
is self-aware without
there actually
being a person behind it.
So if that-- if each such
experience is a pearl,
then we are like a string
of pearls strung together.
Somehow the brain
manages to take
all these individual
experiences, each one of which
has a sense of
self-referentiality
and somehow
constructs this larger
sense of being a person to which
all these things are happening.
And there might be no person.
And that's where the
whole self, no self debate
hits-- that's where the
rubber meets the road.
It really is-- it ties
in with the hard problem
of consciousness trying to
explain how does consciousness
arise in a brain that
is material and physical
and yet seems to give rise to
something that is not seemingly
material.
And right now neuroscience
really doesn't have an answer.
Philosophers disagree on whether
science will ever answer it
or whether the problem
will just go away
the more we understand
the brain-- we don't know.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
meta-question ready.
So I think this is particularly
true of modern physics
and neurobiology that
there's the science
and there's the
interpretation of science.
And the interpretations
tend to vary widely
based on the same science.
So what do you think
is your narrative bias?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: My narrative
bias-- my cognitive bias--
probably tending more towards
evidence-based science.
Is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: Again, more
from what I know, again,
a layman in both these fields,
but more true of physics.
Based on the same evidence,
the interpretations
can still vary because
a lot of, again, I'm
going back to physics.
A lot of the research
is essentially math.
And a lot of the
interpretation is
trying to make sense of
it that somehow matches up
with our common sense in
the everyday experiences.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: I'm
not sure that physicist
will agree with that.
I think physics is really
trying to explain the material
world in some sense.
Yes, there are
mathematical frameworks,
like string theory
for instance, which
are well-motivated, but haven't
yet intersected experiment.
So I don't think
physicists would
say that their math or
the science that they do
is open to interpretation.
In some sense,
they are basically
explaining the physical world.
And there are-- you're right.
There are mathematical
frameworks
that haven't yet
intersected experiment
and hence is open
to interpretation.
But that is slightly
different from saying here's
a body of physics and math
that actually has been tested.
And that is open
to interpretation.
That is not open
It's those frameworks
that haven't yet
intersected with experiment
where the interpretation comes
in.
Or quantum mechanics where--
that's a really, really
weird part of physics.
And so there are
interpretations about what
is happening when you observe
things at the quantum level.
Yes, I agree.
But things like the
many worlds hypothesis
or the Copenhagen
interpretation.
And I think that's
because at this point,
we just don't have enough
experimental means to delve
into reality in ways that
can answer or resolve those.
They're all open to
interpretation at this point.
AUDIENCE: So you think
that neurobiology
is at a point where we
are more realistic in what
we can say [INAUDIBLE]
man based on the science?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
Is it more realistic?
No, I think there is a lot of
hype about neurobiology also.
I think we have to be careful.
In my book, I talk a
lot about brain scans
and looking at the differences
in brains of people,
say, suffering
from once condition
versus healthy controls
and things like that.
But we have to be really
cautious that when
you are talking
about differences
in the brains of people.
We're basically
seeing correlations.
And it has to be very
strongly emphasized
that what's being seen is a
correlation between a snapshot
of someone's brain at a
given point in their lives
with what they are subjectively
experiencing within.
It doesn't establish causation.
And we do get carried
away by thinking
that these things are
actually explaining
the cause of something.
They're not at this point.
To study causation would require
longitudinal studies and a very
different kind of study.
MALE SPEAKER: So we'll have
time for a few more questions
during the book signing.
But I want to close
with two for now.
The first one's a little tricky.
I'll admit it's kind
of hard to phrase.
We were talking
about it earlier.
So what I loved most
about the book is
there are so many
little anecdotes.
You share a story.
It kind of captivates you.
There's a confusing
thing that's going
on-- a confusing phenomenon.
Doctors will kind
of give they're take
and sometimes will give
us a bit of a resolution.
And early in the book,
one of the resolutions
is the self is linked to one's
body, one's story, and one's
social and cultural milieu.
Brain, body, mind,
self, and society
are inextricably linked.
What I liked about
this-- what provoked
some thought in me
is I think we take
a lot of these aspects
of our self for granted.
We know we have a body.
We have a mind.
We have feelings--
a sense of self.
But this idea of bringing
society into the equation
is interesting because
I find we blame society
a lot for a lot for things
that we don't like instead
of thinking it may
be, or even realizing
that it's part of ourselves.
So at Google, we take on
a lot of social issues.
We think about them.
We say at Google
society has standards
that women shouldn't be
engineers or women shouldn't
be CEOs or directors or VPs.
And we combat
society in that way.
What I wonder-- my very
long-winded question
is-- if we can acknowledge
that the society--
culture is at some point,
just a part of ourselves.
Does it not liberate
us to then maybe think
about how much we
want to give a voice
to that part of ourselves?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: Yeah, I
think it's really important
to acknowledge the role
of culture and society
in who we are.
We were talking about this
before the talk began.
And I was telling Sajit
that he's off Indian origin?
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: But
he grew up in the US.
I can imagine the same
body growing up in India.
And it will be a
different Sajit.
That culture would have
a very different impact
on him and the
person that he would
be, would be very different
even though biologically,
neurobiologically even, it
would be the same material body.
So the culture--
society is really
a very, very strong
aspect of who we are.
But then who we are then
influences the culture.
So it's a two-way street.
And in some sense it is
both liberating and binding.
You can't escape society.
You can't escape culture.
It's a large part
of what we are.
But we can influence it too.
And so if you see it that
way, then I would say,
yeah, it's liberating.
MALE SPEAKER: Very
cool-- very cool.
Thank you.
A question a lot of Googlers
have been pinging me with
is how does a Bay Area
SUI software engineer end
up going to UC Santa
Cruz to study journalism
and becoming a journalist?
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY: It was just
a 90-mile trip down the road.
No, seriously, it
was around, I think,
I was in Berkeley building
network management systems.
In fact, I have a
colleague from that company
who was here at Google.
I don't see him here.
I think four or five
years into my software job
in Berkeley I really began
to feel the desire to write.
And I thought I would
be writing fiction.
And so I would take a
few months off each year
and try my hand at fiction.
And then somebody
told me what do
you UC Santa Cruz program,
which is science communication
program-- science
writing program.
And that was a really key moment
because I really love science.
And I love reading about it.
And it never occurred to me that
it is something I could write.
So when I found out
about the program,
I said, OK, it's just one year.
How long can I go?
So I went and did the program.
The program led to an internship
with "New Scientist" in London.
So I went to London
for six months.
And I was still
wondering whether I
could earn a living doing
writing So I came back.
And for the first year,
maybe about 10 months,
I did double duty about
three and a half days
of writing more code and
then three and a half days
of writing not code,
but journalism.
And then 10 months
into it, I realized
I could pay my
bills with writing.
And that was it.
After that, I haven't
been writing code.
Though I like writing code.
And don't mistake me.
But I think I like
writing stories much more.
So it wasn't a difficult
transition in that sense.
It's really something
I wanted to do.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
So Anil's new book-- "The
Man Who Wasn't There:
Investigations into the Strange
New Science of the Self"
is a captivating,
thought-provoking read.
It's available today.
Anil, thanks for being here.
ANIL ANANTHASWAMY:
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]